were you bummed when the roast kind of
went away did that bum you out no I was
I was uh I was happy to do three and
done perch for you yeah and it was I
mean it was all I wanted to do I was
like building my act towards getting on
that the Trump roast was like my big
break my life was night and day after
that then the sheen roast came like a
couple months later it wasn't that long
and that was even bigger and that I felt
insane pressure because I was like well
that was my big break and I those were
jokes that I've been working on forever
now I've got four months this is my
sophomore album that could tank and I
didn't want it to seem like oh I got
lucky so that roast was so stressful and
then it was like a year until the
Roseanne was my last one and that was a
let down it wasn't have the same uh like
hype to it that Trump and Sheen had like
the next I remember I showed the next
weekend and like the T ticket sales were
just normal like it wasn't like I didn't
get the bump that I got after Sheen and
Trump that I was like you know I don't
really want to do this anymore it's like
it's just not fun telling the same kinds
of jokes and I didn't approach it like
Jeff Ross who was just like Jeff Ross
could do it forever right to anyone no
one's getting mad he's just perfect at
it my thing was like too like Darth
Vader like I was coming to kill everyone
there and it just I didn't want to do it
again that people ask me every now and
again I'm like it would take it would
take a lot it would it would have to be
money because I just feel like I've done
it and I feel like I did it perfectly
right that to come back it just I feel
the pressure you know I feel the
pressure to perform like the audience
might be there to see me and they've
loved my last four hours but this fifth
hour better measure up or I feel
terrible
hype yeah and I guess once you do
something and doing it well then that's
enough knowing when to not do something
anymore is important do you think Comedy
Central how' they mess up I mean they
were they were the only comedy network
via com [__] it up for everybody at a
time when Disney was buying Marvel at a
time where Disney was buying you know
like Warner Brothers all this [__]
Viacom was just like enriching
themselves they weren't investing and
then when streaming came along it just
wiped them all out but like MTV's gone
and Comedy Central is still technically
around but it's like five people now and
they're not getting to stand up that
maybe things come back a little bit but
it was just and I've talked to many many
people over there over the years about
what happened but it this crazy though
like you were the Comedy Network MH you
had comedy yeah I remember it took them
forever to get into like social they
just didn't they were like so behind
somehow so behind yeah just didn't
didn't really care that much didn't have
to but they're figuring out now and they
made some B they just didn't have they
didn't have that good a p like they only
had a few shows that really crushed it
for him I think you know and they
wouldn't pay to get three seasons was
almost impossible even two was like a
stretch I mean look it's like SNL you
see the people who like didn't get who
like auditioned for SNL and didn't get
her got fired after a year you know and
their careers how amazing it's been like
a Sarah Silverman or something um that
uh Comedy Central is the same way it's
like all these huge stars that like
people think Comedy Central let them go
it's like they couldn't afford them yeah
what John Oliver's what um not John John
Oliver's making HBO versus what he made
on Comedy Central is insane uh Steven
coar you know had to leave at Comedy
Central they just didn't have the money
there yeah Schumer owed them uh Amy
Schumer owed them another season I think
of her show I don't know if she ended up
doing it or not but I remember she had
the what is this show called inside am
inside am Schumer I think they
contractually had one more season that
she was supposed to do because then she
just blew up so much that she just
didn't and maybe they just did like a
buy out of it or something I just
remember she did it she did one for
Paramount plus oh she did oh maybe that
was it then yeah maybe that was it
um I was I have friends who would like
sign a deal get paid and then like hope
the network forgets about it oh yeah was
like quby remember quibby oh yeah God I
wish I had taken a deal from them this
free money deals yeah they're like
here's 100 grand three weeks later they
were totally out of business like what's
the best job you've ever had in terms of
that like for me it was uh judging roast
battle MH where it was just like every I
go I show up oh yeah like you're you're
they're they're paying you amazing and
you don't have to prepare anything you
just sit there and then they do their
bit and then you think of a joke and you
say it and then it's everything it's
great and if you mess up they edit it
out like it's so cool zero pressure paid
paid uh a ton and uh and just so much
fun I love that that was yeah one of the
best jobs I ever had actually was a
Comedy Central job it was called um
Reality Bites back I watched I watched
Reality Bites back uh Amy had it all on
like DVD and we watched it show was so
[__] funny I can't believe it didn't
like no one watched it but it was it was
great I can't believe they didn't start
to reair things that they had that were
great but I guess they don't have is
that a fiscal maybe they have to rerent
it from themselves I don't know how that
works I think just no one watched it no
one was watching it if they would rerun
it they were just like let's let's get
rid of this but it had like Schumer on
it uh a uh Tiffany hadish Berke chry
like if they put it out now it seemed
like it would do fine yeah you would
think you know
it's it's weird how comedy doesn't live
that long even if it is all like the
stars of yesterday people just they'd
rather watch you now but it's like I can
watch like uh Summer Heights High right
have you ever seen that oh yeah and uh
and it'll it's still get it's still like
so rid it still gets me but it's like I
mean one of the best shows Comedy
Central ever made was um Strangers With
Candy and they never ran that like ever
you have to like you had to find it on I
used to buy it on eBay I'd buy like a
season on eBay for someone who burned
like the DVDs that sh was amazing my
favorite roast of all time was the roast
of Chevy Chase the one that was like a
fiasco but it's like Todd Berry Andy
Kindler like Mark Marin of the roosters
and it's so [__] awesome but it
tanked and they like Comedy Central was
just like we threw it away like you
can't if you can find it on YouTube go
for it but we don't have a copy of it
we'll never rerun it and we just got rid
of it that's crazy it seems like if you
put the roast of Chevy Chase on a
network TV right now people would tune
in like what do you think about like our
Netflix specials like things we've done
there's no physical media anymore like
that can all go away and you're left
with like nothing and that's wild to me
that a corporation who knows what you
get canceled for but they can just be
like all your work is gone it's gone as
if it never existed and there's nothing
you can do nothing oh it's very scary I
think you know I went to the last
Blockbuster not long ago where's that
it's in Bend Oregon yes and I have an
ex-girlfriend that lives up there and
it's a beautiful town and uh and I went
in there and you know what's fascinating
the most fascinating was how you used to
see you saw so many titles you're over
here it's like in Brugge and here's like
you know uh Daddy Daycare or whatever
you know here's like you know uh llama
town or whatever and it's like oh [__] I
you don't know what to choose but you
see so I mean you were here and then you
were in and you'd walk through you be
like I oh I forgot about this movie this
is great I've never seen this but it was
so different than when you go to a
platform on your television and you see
titles it was another it felt like you
actually here's what it felt like I'm
realizing it felt like you actually had
a choice in what you were choosing MH in
the Blockbuster right then as opposed to
on the TV where it feels like this is
what you we we're serving today even
though that's not it you can go look for
stuff but it's just not it what it
didn't register the same no and it's
it's even annoying where Netflix I don't
know they still do this but like if they
know your something's right up your
alley like they have all your algorithm
whatever there was a movie that came out
like a couple years ago right before my
like last special came out and I I was
talking to Netflix at the time and have
you ever seen the Night Comes for us did
you ever see the raid or The Raid 2 it's
kind of like a martial like a super
violent martial arts movie where people
are just fighting with like machetes and
[__] and it's awesome and I see it I'm
like this is the best [__] thing I've
ever seen why would Netflix tell me hey
good news we got this new movie for you
and so they told me basically if they
know you're going to see it if they know
like this is right up your alley they
won't put it on your screen because they
know you'll go look for it and they want
you to find other things on your way to
it that's like you can't they know what
you want but they're still going to make
you look for it and that makes me
[__]
crazy